day I will show you some machine
learning stuff and it's very specific
it's not only machine learning but it's
newer networks and zero slides all I'm
showing you in this next 30 minutes is
this thing and unfortunately even though
it's very powerful is it's a great thing
it overwhelms you when you when you file
at all and how do you do that like this
it's called playground dot ten o'clock
and when you start it looks like it I
think they made a mistake in showing too
much at first but first thing we will do
is disable all that stuff so if you try
it at home you scroll down and then you
find if you check boxes and then you
uncheck all of it
no double-clicking I'm very bad at that
you see it may take five minutes sorry
I'm checking all of them people check
some of them again later but first I'm
check over then refresh the page oops
and looks like this so it's much simpler
now because a lot of stuff has
disappeared the main thing the main
thing or the thing that you should use
to get started on the right side here
and what you see is a two dimensional
coordinate system and on that coordinate
system you have dots the blue ones and
the orange one and it works like this so
this is pressed axis it's called x1 and
this is the second one it's called x2
and what do you have here as an axis
this one x1 x2 is this thing here also
called x1 and x2
so this is important to know that
there's some sort of like like
connection between those two and works
like this and so each of those parts is
one orange one every one it is somewhere
on that coordinate system so the input
for something has to be x1 x2 so simple
now what the whole system tries to do is
you fit in all those blue points and we
feed in all those orange points and what
the system is supposed to do is to learn
in which area of that calling system
will blue points appear and in which
area will orange point and of course
it's City to do this unless you want to
do predictions later so this is what you
see now is it's the so-called training
set which you feed into the system so
you tell this whole system here at a
certain point and it should be blue and
it changes something in that system
elbow shoulder and later you feed in
something that you haven't seen before
and then you hope that the system will
make a good prediction so for example if
something appears here or color blend it
has what would you say
what is it all right right and for us
it's very easy because we're very good
at something like pattern recognition we
see the pattern so there it looks like
like a circle in the middle and rest
properties already we see that because
we have brains we can do that but the
machine it has to learn it and now I
will try and make the Machine done that
stuff and by the way if you have
questions I know it's a big room but
just shout I don't know so um now I'm
trying to change the system but I can't
because I'm check too many boxes so
there's the play button and the play
button it actually starts the whole
training thing you can do
something else a motion layer set button
is also interesting so you would see the
effect of this in the second so test
data is also good level that we don't
need it so picking refresh so if you
want to repeat that you do this the same
thing and now all of a sudden if this
button is the play button and the reset
button and you can do something like
this I'm just making it simpler so what
I did is I configured the neural network
like the architecture of the network and
I told the whole thing just to use a
simple and single neuron so those are
the input to remember that this X 1 this
is X 2 and this is a so called simulate
in Europe and what it can do it takes
two inputs this one it multiplies it
with weight the weight that you see
there and you can change it like
manually I'm doing it now and by
changing it you see that something on
the right side chain you see that this
is very big way and you see it expressed
in the thickness of this this connection
and I can also change this thing it's
like multiplying this input with a
certain number and what I'm trying to do
like many of you right now is to what
I'm trying to maybe you tell me what
what is it then I'm going to do you I'm
trying to adjust those ways that this
thing here this whatever this is I am
trying to separate the blue dots from
the orange dot but what you can see
maybe you see it is whatever I change
here all I get is a light you see this
is like the like how hard is this place
and the the slope the speediness of the
line I can change or changing those
weights you see that
but what I cannot change is that it's
the line and this is because this is how
a neuron works like a simulated neuron
what it does actually is to sum up those
things as I said multiplied with weight
then put it through so-called activation
function twitches should not concern you
and then it outputs something and this
makes the prediction I'm dry I'm drawing
it for a second round so what it does
here is x1 times weight 1 plus X 2 times
y2 and if you do this like in a in
equation you may know that this is
actually the equation for what
mathematically book it's a lie right so
if you if you do some sort of
transformation at a certain point you
get something like I know steepness
times X plus offsets and it'll be and
this is this is the equation for life
so what you see is in single you earn
can draw a line and this is what it does
right is it a good line I mean is it
good it's that line good at separating
the blue dots from the orange dots is it
good it sucks
right because you don't even you can
only see it but there's also a measure
up here and it helps you how good it is
at it and it is not even 50% so 53% are
wrong
so this is a very bad line but I started
like doing this manually but what I can
do is I let this run
it's still such a lot I reset it sorry
settle sometimes it was run now and
outward it as it tries very hard to like
draw the line properly and I can go and
come as meta it will try for a while but
now you can see there curacy up here
like how well is doing it's 40%
no it's the other way around so no it's
right no worries so 40% is wrong so 40%
is still wrong would you be able to draw
the line in a way that it could actually
separate the blue from the orange things
it was a circle that's 2 but if it is a
light not possible as a circle thing I
think it's even possible here let me see
it should be this right it doesn't make
any sense so let's see holy goodness so
with the circle it's possible and you
see the test gloss it's it's almost you
so it's almost possible with a circle
and but this this was something like a
trick this is unusual probably most of
the time you don't pre process the
inputs but you use just the line but I
think if you stick to a line we really
see that it's not possible to ever get a
good result line because there's just no
way what I can do now and this is the
like the trick of the neural network if
you add neurons and I'm doing it
second one so the initial weight which
is the thing that is actually variable
is that he can change the initial weight
it's just random
it's just something now when I'm
starting the training let's see that now
you use two lines and you see how they
look how they look by looking at this
with visualization here this is the
first time this particular
and now they're combined in a way that
they form this shape and now the test
laws like how many wrong predictions you
have with the testing thing is 18
percent it's much better do you think if
I keep on training would be possible to
get close to zero no certain I'm good
I'll do it that line I reset that and as
you may have expected after a while you
get something that's pretty close to a
triangle because you're free line right
it's not perfect but it is very close to
well still goes down I think we get very
close to at least less than 1% so this
actually fixed the whole thing so this
was good enough this was was a preview
of thing so you can keep adding things
no it's wrong sorry or neurons
more batteries brain good you can't see
it but my cell actually started like
working here my machine but quite
intense for this small machine that she
can't calculate that prediction and you
see this thing here is totally useless
anything this thing is useless probably
already have too many of those but I
could still keep anything doing it again
okay what works so it doesn't get any
better or much better so we see probably
good architecture for new your net three
of those now next thing I said the real
purpose of this is not to get a very
good prediction for the so called
training set like the the dots that I
feed in but for something else like four
dots that I have not seen before yet and
this thing actually can do it I think I
need to check one more box should be
called
I know there's something that's called
test you see it anywhere
where is it
I have
oh good yes it is all the places now you
see two losses here I don't know why we
didn't see it earlier and this is
because there's two sets of dots here I
think it's hard to see but some of those
dots they have a black surrounding like
back black borders and has a white
border you see that is it possible and
the data that I used to train the whole
thing it has obviously it has a white
border but there's another set of data
and this set of data it has black
borders this is like randomly splitting
your group like the amount of
information that you have it is
something they use for training to start
with the white borders and it is
something that you use for testing like
how well did I do and you get two losses
now you get one for testing that's
useful like sorry the other way you get
one for training that you use to train
the network and the yellow fantastic and
that's let's have a look and you also
get like to grasp on I see that it's
slightly diverting here they're both
going down still going down so training
is a little bit better than test but
only with a very small margin and what
we say if you if you had the training
result like this is a good result as a
bad what do you say like intuition good
it's a good one it's pretty good so this
is exactly what we wanted so some of
those spots we didn't know that they
would be there but we just save that for
later and we can actually choose how
many of them this is 50% like splitting
50 for training and 50 protesting and
that's quite unusual spread like this
but it's a default you often see 60 for
training and 14 for testing or even 80
for training and 20 for testing it
depends it depends how how many data
sets you want to save to make very sure
that that you have very good results and
it also depends on how many data sets
you have at all
to change it to I don't know eggie think
this is pretty common so that means 80%
of those thoughts used for training and
20 for testing it's still good still
works well but you can do something else
or we can see something else
with the whole thing and this is when I
make the your network ridiculously
complex and I can do it so this thing
allows me to have one so-called hidden
layer this is a hidden layer and has
three new yarns but the whole thing
allows me to add layers like this quite
a few we already know that the
complexity is too high now what it means
we will see in a second because we knew
when we saw that just one single layer
the three neurons it was enough right
like the model waswas complex enough in
the architecture and it's even
mathematically approvable that a single
layer always is enough to solve any
problem in theory practically it's not
but it's provable that any is a
continuous function can be approximated
using the single thin layer but
sometimes it's just not practically
feasible and then you can keep on adding
layers and it may be give me
Lennie's here showing you something that
I didn't prepare any slides and to lie
to another form there they go this is
the architecture of the Google Network
the inception network for classifying
pictures and each of those things here
of these is a layer so there are many
layers and it's a is branching those
this would be like the complex model for
something that's real
not-not-not something like separating
the orange dots from the blue dots
because this thing is you can can see in
a picture what is not the picture like
an example maybe hold it's funny example
this is this reCAPTCHA it's real so I
didn't get it some some somebody else
had to like choose three dogs it's not
very easy especially this thing here and
this and I don't know is this puppy so
is it nothing I think we can do it and
this thing that I just showed you I said
this Qi ba ba it's a chihuahua I didn't
know before I fed it into tensorflow
like the full version of the playground
and this is the result that I got so it
had like 86 percent it was very sure
like 86 percent sure that it's a she
mother I had no idea that it was a fear
while I thought with the dog for the
random dog so actually that capture this
thing here of sorry this thing here
actually it was meant to like tell the
robot from the human but it's no longer
possible like do it because the machine
can can tell me which is the muffin and
which is
already but if you want to do it this is
our Center and as I said each of these
things is a layer it has many neurons
inside and you may know we may like
understand and believe that training
such a thing is very expensive and you
need a lot of data trainer and I could
do it like with all my mind so that was
like an excursion you can go practically
no yeah so I'm doing as much as I can
now but moneth fixing layers I can't I
can keep on adding neurons here I'm
trying to achieve something to give me a
second so now I'm beginning the training
and it doesn't look good right
goes down something good happens oh it's
a good sorry I have to do it again
because it's quite good it should be
shitty
sorry and it's always like it you can
never reproduce the results even in a
few you have the same like architecture
and setup of the system there's a lot of
random stuff inside maybe I'm changing
this for a while generator
let's see
oops as I said so that's random stuff
inside no training possible in that case
okay good
they're not good
you see I'm um getting nervous
it should be shitty give me a second
so if it doesn't work I would have to
like tell you what I was trying to
achieve it's still so good I have no
idea why so I will tell you what I'm
trying to achieve something maybe
someone can help me to mess it up it
should be really bad okay last try if it
doesn't work then I would just explain
what I was trying to achieve you know
okay what I was trying to achieve when
the tipping worked quite well I was
trying to get those two curves it
actually took curves one curve for the
training loss and one for the test loss
to get them out of sync like to have
them one very good and one very bad more
complex data said not possible I thought
I should try a more complex model but it
just doesn't cut it
ah good idea that should be really bad
there yes yes
yeah but almost I don't stop it now wait
I will have at least fake the curve yes
now huh oh sorry okay last try
increase it
let's see or let's say this is the
finals I dunno I'm just not getting it
done and if you saw something like the
likely loss for the training is very low
but the loss for the test is high what
will you say is that still a good test
result is all still good training done
what do you say and what does it mean
you could visualize it here so I'm
having it very hot oh wait I don't I
know how to actually like that think
about it
I'm trying to fix it I'm using a more
complicated that's what you said right
it's possible although it was not
possible so what we're doing now I'm
using a more complex data set like a
mean data set and I'm trying it again
it's not fair yes there was just a
perfect it's exactly like I thought it
should be like the result is still not
good but getting better now always
perfect thanks a lot so what it tries is
like to do very good separation between
those two things it doesn't do very well
yet I think we would have like have it
run for a bit more time I see things are
actually much more complex now and it's
getting better all the time you see the
the training thing goes down all the
time but the testing it goes up right
this is exactly what I was trying to
show it obviously was hard to show it
with a too simple data set and it's you
see this will go on for quite a while
even one with this very simple thing on
my machine it will probably take like 10
minutes until it actually is very good
at predicting but you see those two
things are not out diverting what does
it mean like what does it mean
it's called overfitting right but what
does it mean I actually did very good at
training with my training data but in
real life which is represented as the
test data I totally suck I'm not even as
old okay I just crossed 50% but this is
getting this is just like I'm as good as
getting so what it means is this model
here this thing here is still too
complex so that it is very good at
exactly predicting those things if I
keep on training but it's very bad at
seeing new things so it's always like
like almost an art to make the model and
then the the training just as complex
too should be general enough to make
predictions when you think and this is
where we're messed up and this is just
sort of like like the spiral it's not
very hard it's a very simple thing it's
just two dimensions now think about
training for for data yeah 1 million
dogs like though you don't want to just
recognize those dogs but off in yellow
and you can also see this here it's
pretty cool if you know like I did not
how to probably set it up and because
time is overall most I will again check
all of those so if you try it yourself
that you can see how will look if you
start it and there's much more stuff but
all of those stuff you should probably
just ignore for from the beginning
because it's over so this thing here you
just ignore these things this is for
like how the training looks and this is
totally esoteric stuff so even though
like the most advanced people I talked
to they say it means something it's less
data tape I read it but it's almost
impossible to explain maybe maybe the
young can do it in in tweets I'm trying
to implement to make a do it but you
probably won't ever touched it so this
is something you will never touch so
probably you just wanna deactivate it
that's from my side we still have three
minutes other questions anything you
like it will you try it at home who will
actually try it at home and do something
with so many people this is like this is
what I try to achieve maybe we have a
quick look at the other data set this is
super simple it's just one line right
this is harder this is the hardest
so what I'm doing here I did this for
the circle remember the circle thing is
that I'm pre percent in the input I'm
not just using the pure input but this
is also common in machine and yet you do
something to the input before you
actually feed it into the machine
learning and if you choose the right
thing which I may have chosen now Liana
isn't fooling me then it might work well
and we start with the circle that we
actually could do it with one urine that
probably takes whatever on my machine
right
so I know it's affair it's you watching
me play you can do it yourself
I thank you if it if you remember like
half of what I said you should be up to
my level
at least and then be able to try that
out it's almost half cool
okay maybe just if there's no no
question you can finish it off with this
entertaining part starting those slides
copy your chicken wing I got all of them
right but there's one thing this is like
bagel or a dog and this is really very
hard and this thing was the hardest is
it is it like the bottom of the dog or
is it a loaf of bread and this thing
here this is this thing here up there I
got it wrong
but then I thought it was a loaf of
bread but then I saw the teeth you see
it's a dog so with that I think they are
now good to close it and thanks a lot
try it out at home
[Applause]